good morning John you are a stupid idiot
and I say this lovingly as your brother
and with complete certainty because we
are all stupid idiots and we all know
the stupid things that some people do
like some of us are racists and some of
us pay $600 for a Gucci person some of
us watch the Jersey Shore we are stupid
that is clear the question is why and
today I'm gonna talk about one of the
reasons that we are stupid it's not the
only one but it is a big one and it is
called bias now we all know what bias is
bias is that inclination that other
people have to ignore are perfectly
legitimate and sometimes even much more
legitimate perspectives now we ourselves
we just have tiny amounts of bias
whereas other people have a huge amount
of bias and yes this is a kind of bias
the type of bias that I just displayed
that I think other people have more bias
than I do is called blind spot bias it
is one of hundreds of categories of the
category of bias cognitive bias and it's
biased that we have in our brains and
the bias blind spot is a kind of
cognitive bias now bias exists for a
reason we are constantly making
decisions at a moment's notice
based on tons huge volumes of
information we need bias in order to
simplify that decision-making process
however if we are unable to overcome our
bias or uneven even to notice our bias
if we are stuck in our bias blind spot
then we are bound to make bad decisions
now John because it is so
extraordinarily difficult to get over
your own blind spot by us I'm gonna need
to talk about someone else's bias and
have someone I was gonna bathroo you and
it's really convenient that you have so
many because you're such an idiot so he
was really fascinating an important bias
it's called the anchoring bias the
anchoring bias is when you buys one
piece of information over all other
pieces of information so for example
John if you met a girl and she was hot
nice and funny and like socially active
and really awesome if she hated the
mountain goats you would not care about
any of that other stuff the mountain
goats are a bias anchor for you and
there's so much of a bias anchor that
you think you are right when you
discount the opinions of people who do
not care or do not enjoy the mountain
goats music there was once a study done
on anchoring bias in which people spun a
wheel and on the wheel were numbers
between 15 and 65 they spun the wheel
landed on a random number then they were
asked how many countries are there in
Africa people who spun a 15 Sedna
purrs close to 15 people who spawn a 65
guests closer to 65 as if the random
spinning wheel had some effect on how
many countries there were in Africa we
have these little bits of information
and we get stuck on them there's also
something called the confirmation bias
and this is even more insidious once you
have made it pay mind about said hot
female who does not like the mountain
goats then you find all kinds of other
things that you don't like about said
hot female you seek out the bad things
about her to reinforce the belief that
you already held because we as humans
once we hold beliefs are programmed to
reinforce those beliefs at the expense
of gallant acres and puns and tons of
evidence to the contrary this is why
science is great by the way because it's
one of the only cultural constructions
that has ever actively worked day-in
day-out to eliminate bias in every way
possible and there are so many more
Authority bias which is basically
anchoring by accept that you're
anchoring on a specific source of
information not just a specific piece of
information there's egocentric bias
where we tend to remember things that we
do in a positive light which leads to
stories about how big your fish was
there's biases with very simple and
obvious names like the wishful thinking
bias and then there are some that have
very strange name like hyperbolic
discounting and that is the bias that
has people who win the lottery taking
one much smaller lumps unwrap our Jura
mount of money over a greater period of
time because we are stupid now it's not
hard to see how bias can go super super
wrong like Nazi Germany wrong but bias
can also hang you up in everyday
decision-making like when you're buying
a car when you're interviewing for a job
or when you're interviewing someone else
for a job so I encourage everybody to go
out and read about bias so you can
eliminate your bias blind-spot there's a
great new book called the believing
brain by four guys named Michael Shermer
who's a columnist in Scientific American
which is one of my very favorite
magazines John I will see you on Friday